>> Rick: THANK YOU, POMINVILLE.
SINCE YOU CENTER
ICE.
BEHIND THE NET.NG
A LITTLE OVER A MINUTE TO GO IN
THE POWER PLAY
THROUGH CENTER ICE AND KNOCKED
DOWN WITH APPARENTLY NONICE IN .
TIPPED FREE AND
>> Rob: GOO OF
THOMPSON.
WE COME THEH A QUICK SHOT.
HERE IS OTTAWA OOMPSON.
THOMPSON SENDING IT BACK TO THE
PASS, WORKING IT DOWN LOW AND
SENDING IT BACK TO THE BLUE
LINE.WN COMING IN AND
DAHLIN A NICE PLAY.
TAKES THE BATTLE FOR IT ON THE
BOARDS.
NOW IT'S KEPT IN BY OTTAWA.
A GREAT PLAY AND WALKING IN
BEON STANDS TALL AND
DEFLECTS THAT OFF OUT
THERE!
BOUNCES ACROSS ICE BUT KNOCKED
DOWN AND OTTAWA BACK AT FULL
STREEND.
OAK PKPOSO
PUNCHED AROUND BEHIND THE GOAL.
YOU WANT TO HAVE A BIG SHIFT
FOLLOWING UP THE GOAL WHERE YOU.
CHIPPEDHACK,  PRETTY GOAL.
OTTAWA CONTROLS THE PLAY.
FLIPS IT DOWN IT  THE PUCK.
SEE THEFREE.
IT CAME RIGHT BESIDE THE NET
AGAIN AND ROLTHERE.
YOU COULD SEE IT FROM AND WORKE.
HE KEPT THE STICK
THE SHOT.
THEY SCORE!
OTTAWA P TO THE PUCK.
HE PULLED ITTIES
FROM THAT SPLASH AT THE END AIR.
OTTAWA T GOALPOST AS IT WAS NIC
HOLDEN WHO LET THEPUCK IS COMINN
AND HE HANGS ON
WITH IT.
4:52 REMAINING IN THE THIRD
PERIOD.
REAK IT UP.
SPUN OUT TO CENTER ICE.
AGAIN, BUFFALO MAKES A CHAN NET
SEAL THE TKACHUK.
EMPTY